[Music]
whether you're a pro or an amateur
there's one goal that every competitor
shares identify myself boy is feeling
just a little bit off the end and to do
it okay
the allure of absolutely redefining your
game breaking the mold when it matters
most and overcoming the odds to vanquish
your greatest foe
there's just no better way to win than
to break the game and it's in those
moments that legends are born
[Music]
Korean League of Legends in 2014 was all
about Samsung at the time the
organization owned two teams Samsung
blue and Samsung white and throughout
2014 blue always seemed to have the
upper hand over their sister team all
that despite the fact that white or
ozone as they were known in spring were
the clear favorites especially heading
into the spring bracket stage and it was
in that bracket then the two sister
teams faced off for the first time
tonight is our first semi-final match
it's a samsung face-off samsung blue vs.
samsung ozone
I love Inter team matches or intra team
matches I guess you could say when its
sister teams facing off against each
other all bets are off
Samsung would decimated their
counterparts three two one ozone just
couldn't keep up with blues raw team
fighting skills they're gonna turn Honda
Samsung owes a double kill for Dante
already vadas don't on the fight
completely at heart spirit chasing him
how to pass the flash away depth of the
kill that gives him time to run away
dandy coming over the top of the 1a wild
growth can they turn this round 8-quart
coming it behind on to it though ya
ain't quartz gonna kill off it been
looper the next to go down
it looked okay for a moment for ozone
but that is it it's no surprise that at
the end of the day Samsung blue will
take it 3-1 they are going to the
champion spring Grand Finals white got
another shot at their biggest rivals in
Champions summer where once again blue
triumphs three two one push out the
fight by mato a little bit a lot of
damage
Todd a pod the last one standing almost
looper of course a relapse insanity but
a double kill for depth that is it that
is going to be the ACE and that will
also be the game Samsung blue coming
back for a 3-1 victory over their sister
after a year of bailing on the biggest
stage it was clear that something had to
change
if Samsung white was ever gonna live up
to their huge potential now let's be
honest the 2014 League of Legends
competitive meta game was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show to watch it wasn't up going one of
you won and Elena and mechanically out
playing your opponent lane swaps
completely shook the framework of the
game link swapping began as a way to
avoid bad matchups in lane but over time
developed into a web of strategic early
gameplay patterns that got so
complicated where I just removed it all
out write your team's goal from minute
one was to attempt to force or avoid a
lane swamp and those decisions would
impact the rest of the game this led to
the prominence of what we now call
vertical jungling junglers would split
the map after the early game lane swap
and group up to push the top lane
uncontested this split map phenomena put
each top laner at such a disadvantage
that they were forced to just follow
their junglers around soaking XP and
giving a farm to say to the jargon the
macro game was everything and yes
you needed a [ __ ] textbook to play
the game at a high level but you have to
basically practice all the major
strategies too like before the game
starts because you can't take two
minutes to say okay guys we're gonna
ward these three brushes then sweep this
one they're gonna go for Dragon in two
waves like at that time that time has
already passed like
steps all have to be practiced out
evidence to know okay guys were doing
the dragon play and then everyone knows
their next minute and a half of step
after their champions matches against
Samson blue it became clear that white
wasn't to be able to fight their way to
a world championship they needed to find
something different something that could
give them the edge they needed to unlock
their true potential and hoist the
summoner's Cup and it was in this
convoluted meta game all about map
control and outsmarting your opponent
that they are able to forego brute force
like Muhammad Ali during the rumble in
the jungle they rope a dope they juked
and dodged and found spots to land a job
here and there all while avoiding the
foreman ask Samsung blue team fighting
right hook knowing that their greatest
weakness was the kind of team fighting
that def da day and the rest of Samsung
blue used to defeat them in Korea all
year they found a strategy that let them
avoid risky fights altogether League of
Legends World Championship Samsung white
used dandy and Amata as a roaming duo a
strategy that was very unique at the
time they prioritized global vision more
than anything and blanketed the map and
wards this macro strategy was just the
edge that Samsung white needed to go six
Andoh in the 2014 World Championship
group stage he's gonna try to flash over
the wall with the rest of his team but
they will continue with the culling
Jorah
so it's EDG they're back you don't
immediately get picked off it's a double
fam
could it be a triple yeah well to the
size of Daphne he's after but not he
will pick up his for kill great Tina
thanks Ari who get played blue pool get
himself 4/3 Kildare still going for this
fight a little bit of crushed controls
going to be good for this one
double kill coming in for him he chooses
a common the triple kill for him
don't ever let the diving board into
battle again exhausting what's he gonna
do his own words green tea daddy will
dive over intensity 4000 why they clean
it up he said ain't forward on the phone
eyes although books as well married into
the top and their first kill coming
straight there daddy will walk of clean
up inside of the Catholicism and will
give implicit they couldn't take the
obey as well this is a whitewash it's a
massacre Samsung white started the
bracket stage against Team solomid the
North American hopeful is looking to
bring down the Korean super team and it
was in that match that Samsung showed
the world that they had conquered the
matter good right of damage coming in
from AZ comes out nicely from looper is
it enough though well turtle takes down
Mata
that's a double kill coming in for him
they start to clean up this fight
without they're all spread out the wrong
positions another answer coming in from
beard sin but they have lost four
members and he's trying to run
south great tempest / [ __ ] actually
doesn't walk down Pierce is just a range
whoo
[Applause]
look at that nexus George this should be
serious amazing it's the neck gasps whoa
oh and he gets the final cue from pod
that's four members down buttes in doing
what he can to stay alive but it's not
gonna be enough white will take down
Team solomid in the quarterfinals and
with that strong performance their
destiny was sealed another shot at
bringing down their rivals another shot
to live up to the hype
this time Samsung white was ready to
rewrite history they were ready for
Samsung blue people take a key you get
into another youth mm lives and regional
Italian Detroit no idea standard put
spin on touch
there is so much history between these
two teams not only because they're
screaming at each other but because they
have a history of meeting in the
semi-final and it's the two big
favorites here before wolves even
started everyone was looking at the
samsung teams good white beat blue maybe
they can then get the title here I mean
we're looking at two giant teams here
two powerhouse here white landed the
first glancing blow blue were on the
ropes early and often see if they bought
the game before the drink oh here come
both teleport down it's gonna be right
on top of each other
Dottie gets what he wants he is gonna be
out of the fight in the intervention on
potables goes down here but he gets the
press control
and white certain things off to us wait
so long
we have a fight against one and there's
the desiccator watch the college for the
backside he's trying to find what he can
death gets hit up there's no feel for
him
Jana's Crumpton did go out but it's soon
his looper is let out of that prison he
is just knocking down the walls binding
mortville a double for him another ace
for Samsung it was utter domination they
flipped the script on their greatest
rivals and avoided the unwinnable
teamfights that lost him those first few
bouts they skirmished like gods one
minute at a time they picked them apart
from both sides the pincer comes in it
will not be stolen that goes the spirit
but it might be his life for the dragon
we see Massa going down first that Dad
default it's going to be a corn but they
have damage right now
ddotty going down weight is going to
start stomping through this fall
to run through the base one more time on
this one just a few minutes extra from
game one thirty two and a half minutes
the Nexus will fall once again the
Samsung white
Game three to a No
in an embarrassing fashion for spirit
Danny managed through three buff him in
Game three they're gonna get three bucks
yep Matson was already at the red book
beer out there running it only we might
see an early fight here it depends if
amp decides to faint over there or quad
beats tea after the punch
well the ward Wars have definitely
already gone down on this one rep up in
the brush the hurricane Wow she said I
want to make it they want to steal the
safety that's a kill going over to
spirit but loopers finalized and set up
one two three with what Lauren now we
eight to three 22 minutes and are
they're really gonna knock it down right
now the quickest in this best-of-five
series and they do not hesitate to drop
the nexus it's only gonna take three
Samsung white finally defeats Sam
such a remarkable fashion three
incredibly one-sided fast games they do
it in such style picking Akali in the
top lane Kassadin in the top lane
assassins in the mid-late really
anything they felt like playing is what
it felt like to finally defeat the team
they cannot get past in this way is
legendary ally and Samsung white have
shown us that to win at the highest
level you can never be too proud you
don't have to go toe to toe the final
blow doesn't have to be flashy
true champions fight smarter to cap off
Samsung White's ascent to the top in one
of the most iconic moments in a league
of legends history diving hand that over
his both other generals jacket to pawn
as a symbol of respect no fun o generals
jacket that da day Wow even with a smile
on his face that is a big moment that is
a jacket dotting never takes off though
it was now a simpler of what just have
amazing amounts of respect Samsung white
went on to defeat star horn Royal Club
in a dominant fashion sealing the deal
and finally lifting the summit has come
sensory is gonna fall only Lulu really
there to serve them the season accessory
for they gonna focus in on the next to
the south and south
champion
[Applause]
what
they're run with so dominant in fact
that some have argued that Samsung
roster was the best in the game's
history and of everything Samsung
accomplished that year that legacy might
be the most significant they reinvented
what seemed like a solve the metagame
and revolutionized it they redefined the
way that pros played around their
junglers and supports Samsung white
changed the game and when it came time
to face a foe they never managed to beat
before they made it work they changed
their game too
and they emerged champions she is what
an extraordinary world championship
samsung white has had if there was ever
a doubt they erased it
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]